MARY GROVE: Good
afternoon, everyone.
How are you?
AUDIENCE: Good.
MARY GROVE: Good.
Great.
Well, welcome to
today's book talk.
My name is Mary Grove,
and I'm the director
of Google for Entrepreneurs,
and it is my privilege
to introduce a phenomenal
entrepreneur and leader, Steve
Case.
Steve is the co-founder
of America Online,
which handled nearly 50% of US
internet traffic at its peak.
It was also the first
ever internet IPO
and the top performing
stock of the 1990s.
Steve is now CEO of the venture
capital firm Revolution, which
he founded in 2005 to invest
in people and ideas that
can change the world.
Steve also champions
this notion of rise
of the rest, the concept that
innovation is thriving not just
here in Silicon Valley,
but all over the country
and really all over the world.
Steve is a member of the
presidential ambassadors
for global
entrepreneurship, and he
is the chairman of the
Case Foundation, which
he and his wife,
Jean, started together
in 1997 to focus on innovation
and inclusive entrepreneurship.
So, Steve, welcome
back to Google.
STEVE CASE: Good to be back.
[APPLAUSE]
MARY GROVE: It's great to
have you back here again,
and you have been a longtime
partner and friend of Google
back from the early days of
our first search partnership.
I was telling Steve over
lunch that back in 2004
when I started at Google we
used AIM as our internal chat.
Now, to Google for
Entrepreneurs we
work very closely
together with your support
for entrepreneurship.
STEVE CASE: I had a great
session this morning at Google
for Entrepreneurs
for those of you
who weren't there whether
11 companies from 11
different cities all
participating in a demo day.
It was great to show the
diversity of talent and ideas
all across the country.
Thank you for doing that.
MARY GROVE: Why don't you tell
everyone about your commitment
that you made?
STEVE CASE: So the idea of these
Google demo days-- and this
is the third one, right?
MARY GROVE: This
is the third one.
STEVE CASE: Is to bring
the different entrepreneurs
from different cities and
match them up with investors.
And so there are
about 100 investors
in the room from
obviously this area,
and hopefully all 11
companies will get investment,
but at the end of it, I
challenge the investors
in the room and said
for any company that
can raise $1 million
in the next 100 days,
I'll personally invest
$100,000 as part of that.
So hopefully all 11 will be
able to use that as a way
both within their communities
to rally support and also get
some support from some of the
investors here in California.
MARY GROVE: Thank
you for doing that.
So you wrote a new
book, "The Third Wave,"
and I want to dig into the
three waves in a moment,
but before I do so,
I want to rewind
a bit to your early days.
So you have always been
incredibly entrepreneurial.
As you said in the book, you
started your first business
with your brother
when you were 10.
I think it was Case Enterprises
going door to door selling--
STEVE CASE: Sounds bigger
than it really was.
MARY GROVE: Selling
greeting cards door to door
in your native Hawaii,
and in college,
you started six side businesses.
So tell me about what you
learned from those experiences.
Maybe if there was a favorite.
STEVE CASE: Well, I
think none of them
were particularly successful,
but I learned a lot
about starting things
and just the curiosity
that I think entrepreneurs
bring to bear
and just trying to see new
possibilities, new angles.
And so I learned,
and a lot of it
was just the
importance of selling
in terms of at least businesses
that don't work automatically.
You have to get guy
somebody to buy something,
and so there were a
lot of times where
I'd be going door to
door selling stuff
and get the door
slammed in my face.
And that's always instructive,
particularly when you're young.
Actually it was easier
when I was really young.
I think when I was 10 or
11 and knocking on doors,
people kind of took
a little pity on me
or just wanted to be supportive.
So I think my sales
track record was
better when I was really young.
Then I moved into my late
teen years, and they said,
who needs to support this guy?
But the sales aspect was always
important, but I got lucky.
When I was in college
in 1980, I read a book
by Alvin Toffler called "The
Third Wave" that some of you
may remember, but
he was a futurist--
still is, still alive, so
he still is a futurist.
Wrote "Future Shock," as well.
And "The Third Wave" really
outlined his framework
to think about what we now
think of as the internet,
but in 1980 it was viewed
as sort of futuristic.
But I was completely
mesmerized by that,
and that led me on the
path to eventually move
into the digital world.
MARY GROVE: Helping create
the first wave, really.
STEVE CASE: But
that's why I decided
to finally write a book.
I deliberately called
it "The Third Wave"
because I wanted to pay
respect for the role he played
in setting me on my path.
MARY GROVE: So the
first wave-- and I
think it's so interesting
for many of us who
work at Google-- the
internet or being
connected all the time
everywhere is almost
an assumption.
And of course, that
wasn't always the case
just a brief while ago.
So tell us about
the first wave era
was about building the internet,
bringing people online.
You say that's roughly from
the mid 80s to the year 2000.
So what was the key insight
that led you to start AOL?
STEVE CASE: Well, some of
it was the Toffler vision,
but when I graduated
in 1980, there
were no internet
companies to go to
and frankly there wasn't
much of a startup culture
back then, as well.
So I worked for a
couple big companies--
Procter Gamble and PepsiCo.
One for two years,
one for one year,
but just trying to figure
out how to get into this.
Moved to the DC area in 1983 to
join a company that I thought
was going to be
the next big thing.
Back then most of you were not
old enough, but a few of you
will remember that in
1983 very few people had
personal computers, but a lot of
people had Atari game machines,
and this was basically a
modem that turned their game
machine into a two way device.
Thought it would be great.
Turned out it was a
disaster, and so immediately
within a month after
joining the company
they laid off 80% of people.
So I was like, ooh,
welcome to the NFL.
This start up stuff is going
to be a little bit risky,
but two of the
people I met there,
and I went off and
started AOL in 1985,
but the insight was we
wanted to get America online.
And at the time we started,
which I know seems crazy,
only 3% of people were online.
And those 3% were
online one hour
a week through mostly
300 baud modems.
And when they connected, on
average they spent about $10
per hour to be connected.
So it was the early
days, and it was
how do we figure out ways to
get more people to buy PCs
and how do we convince the
PC manufacturers to actually
build modems into PCs so it
wasn't a peripheral device.
It was a central device.
How do we reengineer a network
so instead of $10 an hour
it was pennies an hour,
and how do we actually
figure out ways to
get more people online
so if you actually did get
online there were stuff to do
and people to talk to,
because in the early days
it was kind of lonely out there.
And so it went from
at the beginning
of that kind of
consumer internet
era in the mid 80s to 2000ish it
went from essentially a concept
that nobody knew about
or frankly cared about
to something that everybody
saw the value in and went
from nobody connected
to essentially
everybody connected.
So that really was that
first 15 years or so.
MARY GROVE: So you became
CEO at a very young age.
I believe it was 32 or so.
STEVE CASE: Well, it's a little
more complicated than that.
I actually became-- I was
co-founder when I was 26 or 27,
something like that.
And I became CEO when
I was 30, or 30, or 31,
but then we decided
to go public.
And this was 1992--
as I you already
said, the first internet
company to go public--
and there was considerable
concern among our board
and our venture investors
that the public market,
institutional investors probably
would be pretty skeptical
about the idea of the
internet, and so it would be
hard to have a successful IPO.
MARY GROVE: A little age bias.
STEVE CASE: I know
that seems crazy,
and also that it
would be harder still
if there was this 30
year old kid as the CEO.
So actually a few
months before we
went public I was demoted
from CEO to executive vice
president.
Kind of ticked me off,
but I sucked it up,
and then we went public,
and a few months later I
became CEO again,
which others have not
had that-- Larry and Sergey
and Mark Zuckerberg, others
recently.
The 20 something CEO is
not such a big concern now,
but in the 90s, a
30 something CEO
was, but in fairness
when we went
public we had been at it for
seven years-- 1985 to 1992--
and after seven years, we
had 184,000 subscribers.
And we were generating
$30 million of revenue.
So in our IPO we
raised $10 million,
and the market value
was $70 million.
And that was more
common IPOs of the day.
Microsoft, and Apple,
and others basically
went public when they were worth
a few hundred million dollars.
We were a little
on the light side,
and we'd been at
it for seven years.
So the institutional
investor is saying, well,
I get your pitch about
this online thing
and why people
might be interested,
but after seven years only
184,000 people have said yes.
So maybe it's just
a niche market.
The good news obviously
is seven years later
it had gone from 184,000
to like 25 million,
and the market value went
from $70 million to $160
billion dollars.
So the second seven
years was a little easier
than the first seven years.
MARY GROVE: You paved the way
for a lot of those young CEOs
now, and I'm always interested
in people's track record
and what do they
do to get there.
So your second job out of
college was at Pizza Hut.
STEVE CASE: That was a good job.
MARY GROVE: And you had
probably the best title ever.
What was your title?
STEVE CASE: I was director
of new pizza development.
[LAUGHTER]
MARY GROVE: Seriously.
STEVE CASE: You are meeting
the former director,
and what they did was
they paid me money
to travel around the
country and eat pizza.
AUDIENCE: All right.
STEVE CASE: This
was actually my job.
MARY GROVE: No, but you wrote
in the book that-- best title
ever, first of
all-- but you wrote
that you learned a lot about
portability and convenience,
and at the time pizza
delivery, home delivery,
the notion of calzones,
these things were not given.
STEVE CASE: Right.
MARY GROVE: And you've said that
those are two of the attributes
that you later really
took into account when
you were building AOL.
STEVE CASE: Yeah, my first
job at P&G I learned a bunch.
Again, I was only
there a couple years,
but one of the things they did
really quite successfully--
they came up with a new
product, like a new shampoo
or something.
They'd put all
these free samples
and bundle it with
newspapers or other products
to get people to try it
so that-- as some of you
might have received a free AOL
disk at some point in time.
That was inspired in part
by that P&G experience.
And some of the Pizza Hut
experience-- the insight there,
which ties in with some of
the work we're doing together
on the rise of the rest is
that, while innovation obviously
happens within companies,
a lot of innovation
happens on the periphery.
And P&G was much more
of a centralized kind
of top down kind of
organization at the time.
It's shifted since,
but at the time
a very kind of-- focusing
on inventing stuff
within the company, and Pizza
Hut was sort of the opposite,
because it was really
run by the franchisees,
and the innovation
actually happened out
on the field in the periphery.
So rather than stay
in the headquarters
and just try to figure out
in our Pizza Hut tests labs
what the next big thing was that
was the reason to hit the road
and find out what's
happening and which
of those might make sense
for the Pizza Hut system.
MARY GROVE: So fast forward.
AOL had a meteoric rise from, as
you said, valued at $70 million
to then valued at $163
billion in January of 2000.
So let's talk about the
merger with Time Warner,
and you've said that
at the time it really
made sense for both strategic
reasons and financial reasons.
As a CEO, what really pushed
it over the edge for you?
Because you're doing
extremely well.
STEVE CASE: No, it was--
obviously it didn't work,
and I'll talk about
why it didn't work,
but the logic for it,
the strategic logic
was pretty sound.
And in part, it was,
as you might imagine,
the fact that we'd gone from
$70 million to $160 billion
and actually had gone from
I think it was $20 billion
in two years before the
merger to $160 billion
two years later, so it
really was pretty rapid.
And we were a
little worried about
whether that was
sustainable, and so merging
with a company that had
a lot of their businesses
and their combined company
you get $40 billion of revenue
and $10 billion of profit.
Our company alone at the time
was about $5 billion of revenue
and $1 billion of profit.
Because of the
relative valuations,
our shareholders got a
majority of the company
even though we were contributing
a minority of the revenue
and a really small
minority of the profit.
So there was that
diversification kind of play,
but also strategically we knew
we needed a path the broadband.
We were pretty dominant
in narrow band,
but needed that path of
broadband and merging
with the company with
the largest cable systems
would be helpful.
Merging with a company with
significant media assets
on Warner Music, and
Warner studios, and Turner
Broadcasting, and Time Inc,
and HBO, and go down the list,
we thought would
also be valuable.
And Time Warner needed that
path into the digital future,
so the idea of it made sense,
but the real lesson there
was-- I quote in the
book Thomas Edison,
who said over 100 years age,
"vision without execution
is hallucination."
[LAUGHTER]
Having a an idea, having
a vision, if you will,
is important but ultimately
it's about execution, which
ultimately is about people.
And unfortunately the company
was run as different fiefdoms
and silos and never
really came together,
so something like digital
music-- the merger
was 16 years ago--
15 or 16 years ago,
and because we had AOL, which
was the leading internet
distribution, Time Warner Cable,
leading cable distribution,
broadband distribution, and
Warner Music, the leading music
company, how could we not
lead the way in digital music?
Well, we didn't.
Apple did, and then
the reason Apple did
was because they had a
real sharp focus on it,
and the reason AOL
and Time Warner
couldn't was because Warner
Music, and Time Warner Cable,
and AOL not only weren't
working together,
they really weren't even
talking to each other.
They really were running
as independent businesses,
so it was a missed opportunity.
MARY GROVE: I was very
struck in the book
when you talked
about the merger.
It clearly was a marriage of
two very successful, but very
different organizations both in
terms of culture, leadership.
What was behind your decision
not to continue as CEO?
STEVE CASE: Well, that was
sort of pragmatic, because I
actually knew that getting this
merger done would be difficult.
Getting Time Warner
to agree would
be difficult for a
whole host of reasons,
and it would be
impossible if I had not
offered in the first call I
made to the CEO of Time Warner
to step aside as CEO.
So I knew that for
all kinds of reasons
that the likelihood of them
deciding to do it was low,
but the only path would be
to say I'll step aside as CEO
and let you take the lead in
running the combined company.
So it was a very pragmatic
deal related point.
MARY GROVE: So
hindsight is 20/20,
but back now, if you could do it
all over again, would you still
do the merger?
STEVE CASE: I'd
still do the merger,
because I think strategically
there still was that logic.
I would have been smarter
about some of the execution
side of things,
smarter about some
of the people side of things.
I mentioned in the
book, for example,
that not long after the
merger I had proposed,
but didn't really
have the ability
to do it because at that point
I wasn't the CEO anymore,
acquiring Google.
At the time, we
owned 5% of Google
because we did the search deal.
Talked about acquiring Apple.
MARY GROVE: That was a
hugely important deal
in Google's history.
STEVE CASE: And Steve
Jobs went back in
and they were still struggling.
I think the market value of both
Apple and Google at the time
was probably $1 billion, $2
billion, something like that.
And those were things that
probably would have made sense,
and so there are some of those
kind of missed opportunities,
but to me it was more
strategically it made sense.
I'm disappointed it
didn't work better.
I learned a lot of
lessons from it,
but I've tried to
reflect in the book,
but I don't really
question the core decision,
because the strategic
decision was right.
It was the execution
that was wrong.
MARY GROVE: But I love
the thoughtfulness
throughout the book
of really opening up
about these experiences,
and for entrepreneurs,
what they can learn from
your path that you've paved.
So this first era was about
first wave-- getting everyone
online, building the internet.
Now we're at the year 2000.
So the second wave
you talk about
is roughly the next 15 years,
so 2000 through to about 2015,
and you call that the era of
apps and this concept of dorm
room entrepreneurship,
so Facebook
becoming a global platform.
What's been the highlight
of the second wave,
or walk us through
how that unfolded?
STEVE CASE: Well, you
guys have been part of it.
Obviously Google
where they started,
the very end of
the first wave, has
been one of the dominant iconic
companies of the second wave.
So it really is the first wave
if you think about it just
building the internet, building
the core foundation technology,
building the on ramps,
educating people why
they wanted to get connected.
That was really just
that first wave.
The second wave has just been
building apps and services
on top of there, and that has
dominated the last 15 years.
Obviously there are all
kinds of different things,
but at center of
gravity was apps.
The center of gravity in
the first way was PCs.
Center gravity obviously shifted
in the second wave to phones,
and the first wave was
more about infrastructure.
Second wave was more
about apps and services.
So Google obviously is
an incredible example
of that, and Facebook, and
many other examples, as well.
And they've had obviously
a profound impact
on people's lives, global reach.
So it's quite extraordinary
what's happened there.
MARY GROVE: What types
of second wave companies
have you invested in?
What's one or two that
you're most excited about?
STEVE CASE: Well,
we've been focusing
most of our investments on what
we think of as this third wave,
but over the last decade we've
invested a bunch of companies
what, in retrospect, were
pioneers in things that
did pretty well in
the second wave,
but are going to be even more
significant in the third wave.
I'm thinking Apple
10 or 11 years ago,
maybe even 12 years ago.
We invested in
Zipcar, the first kind
of sharing economy company,
and that was later acquired.
So that was an example of
something that early on-- we
made some investments in health
care, several companies there.
That scenario I think is
going to really accelerate
in the third wave.
MARY GROVE: So let's fast
forward to the third wave
then, which you've talked about
as the internet of everything.
Describe to us your vision
for what we should expect.
STEVE CASE: Well,
actually in some ways
Google, or more broadly Alphabet
is a great example of this.
A lot of the businesses that
Alphabet is now focused on
are things that
really are perceived
to be-- I think correctly--
the next big opportunities
in this next wave, whether
it really be about health,
or be about cars, or what
other kinds of things,
but the way I think of
it at a simplistic level
is the third wave is
really integrating
the internet in more
seamless, and pervasive,
and sometimes even invisible
ways throughout our lives.
And some of the initiatives
that maybe some of you
are working on, such
as smart cities,
or how do you re-imagine
education so it is more
personalized and
adaptive, or how
do you rethink and
revolutionize health care so you
can do a better job
of understanding how
to keep people healthy, how
to manage chronic disease,
how to manage more life
threatening diseases
that-- as you probably know
that because of a data problem,
cancer diagnosis is
wrong quite frequently.
MD Anderson says that 25%
of the time when people
come for a second opinion they
reverse the first opinion,
which just isn't acceptable.
There's all kinds of issues now.
I think the third cause
of death is actually
not the actual
disease, but problems
that seep into the system
in various kind of ways,
which basically are mistakes.
And so there's all
kinds of opportunities,
and that's been--
and the food sector.
It's a $5 trillion
dollar industry
that hasn't changed that much.
I think there's a lot of
innovation happening there,
and although at the core
it's about the food,
there's a lot of things
happening with technology,
and supply chains,
and using phones
to order things and
other things that are
going to really change that.
So the first wave, as I said,
was PCs, second wave, phones.
Third wave is about
sensors, and devices,
and really infiltrating
other parts of our society
in ways that can create
a lot of benefit,
but also are going to
create some thornier
challenges, including on public
policy issues around privacy
and things like that are
going to be even tougher.
How do you make sure--
I'm sure obviously
the folks here that are
working on the car effort
are focused on this,
but how do you make sure
that autonomous vehicles can,
in fact, provide benefits,
but they're encrypted in a
way that it doesn't create
significant risk to cities.
And those kind of
issues were not
as central in the
second wave, but they're
going to be front and
center in the first wave.
How to make sure
the food is safe.
How do you make
sure drugs are safe?
How do you make sure
some of these things
in the transportation
sector or the energy sector
are benefits to society?
Are maximized and some of
the risks are minimized?
So the core thesis
of the book is
that, unlike the
second wave, it's
going to require
more partnerships.
This is less about the app,
less about the software,
more about how you connect to
other kind of organization,
whether it be schools,
or hospitals, or cities,
or what have you.
It's going to require
more engagement on policy
because many of these
sectors are regulated.
You might get
frustrated by that,
but the reality is they're
going to be regulated,
so you just have to kind of
understand that and embrace
that.
And they're likely going to
require more perseverance.
I think these are going to
be difficult challenges,
so there'll be fewer of
the overnight successes
like a Facebook or
Snapchat, which were pretty
overnight successy, and
more things that are
going to take 5, 10, 15 years--
MARY GROVE: In the long run.
STEVE CASE: --got a
little bit more of a slog,
but if you bring
that perspective
around partnerships, and policy,
and perseverance to bear,
you can change the world
in pretty profound ways.
And the reason I
wrote the book was I
realized that
while-- again, it's
hard to generalize
because a lot of companies
are doing a lot of
different things,
but in general in
the second wave
it was more about
the app and software.
Partnerships were
less important.
Policy was generally
not that important,
at least until you
got really successful,
and somebody said, well, what
about privacy with Facebook,
or Google, or what have
you, but in the early days
it wasn't a big force.
And perseverance was less
critical because things
tended to happen pretty--
MARY GROVE: Pretty quickly.
STEVE CASE: Pretty quickly.
The first wave really was
defined by those three Ps.
Partnerships were critical.
We had 300 partnerships at AOL.
Policy was critical.
Remember, when we
first started, it
was actually illegal for
consumers or businesses
to connect to the internet--
illegal until 1991
when Congress passed
the Telecom Act.
And also it's worth remembering
that the internet itself
was invented by the government.
The DARPA funding
really is what created
the internet, and the most
important arguably thing that
happened that unleashed the
internet, which doesn't get
talked about a lot, was
when a judge, Judge Greene,
broke up Ma Bell,
the phone company,
into regional Bell
operating companies.
And that created hundreds
of telecom companies instead
of one, which is what
drove down the price,
drove up the speed,
things like that.
So there are a lot of
things that government
did in that sector
in the first wave.
So those three Ps were very
important in the first wave,
not as important
generally the second wave,
are going to become
are much more important
again in the third wave.
MARY GROVE: So let's
talk about those Ps.
Let's about number two, policy.
On the regulation
front, you've talked
a lot about how,
in this third wave,
it's more critical
than ever for companies
to get ahead of regulation,
to work with policymakers.
At Google, we feel
that every day.
So let's talk about Uber.
Is a Ubter-- and you talk
about this in the book a bit.
Is it the exception or the norm?
How they've [INAUDIBLE].
STEVE CASE: Well, it's a hybrid.
I mean, Uber has been
obviously a tremendous success,
and they should be celebrated
for taking an idea, what,
five, six years ago, and now
having such a global presence,
such a valuable
company, but I think
if people say that the lesson
of Uber is to ignore the laws,
jump into the market,
try to get traction,
and then use that traction and
consumer ability to mobilize
consumers to change
the law, they probably
are going to be in
trouble in the third wave
for the same reason
that Uber is now
in trouble in countries like
Germany and South Korea,
where they're shut down.
What happened with Uber is sort
of a unique, which is the laws
were highly localized.
So they said they could
fight hundreds of battles.
They win some.
They lose some, and the
basic rules generally
were perceived by
consumers to be protecting
the incumbent taxi
companies as opposed
to enabling innovation
that's good for consumers.
That's what drove that.
There are many
sectors that are going
to be important in the third
wave, like health care.
If you think you can basically
ignore the laws around drugs
and just offer something without
going through that process,
you are wrong, and you will
be put out of business.
And similarly, things
around food safety
or other things around drones,
or autonomous vehicles, things
like that-- there are
going to be regulations
you have to adhere to be
able to be in the market
and generate revenue.
It's not just about
something that you
can fight some skirmishes
around the side.
So when I say
that-- because I've
talked to a bunch of
people about these issues
that in this third
wave it's going
to require partnerships
which are hard, take time,
sometimes frustrating.
That's kind of a bummer.
You say it's going to require
more engaging with policy
and dealing with
government and regulators.
That's kind of a
bummer, and you say
it's going to require
more perseverance.
It's going to take
longer and be a slog.
That's kind of a bummer, too.
And so there are a lot of people
who hear this thesis and say,
I think I'll stay
on the second wave.
I think I like apps.
I think I don't really
want to deal with things
that require partners.
I'd rather go alone.
I don't really want to
deal with government.
I don't to deal
with regulations.
I'd like they have overnight
successes, thank you very much.
And some will make
that decision,
but I think some of
the big opportunities
are going to-- there
are huge opportunities
in the third wave, but
are going to require
this different mindset and
a little different playbook.
MARY GROVE: As an
investor, how much
does regulation impact
your decisions to invest?
So for example, if you're
looking at a drone company who
is dealing with FAA
regulations that there's
such a long lead
time on reform there,
does that influence
your decision?
How do you think about it?
STEVE CASE: It influences.
We're not naive about
some of those risks,
and we're not rushing
to things that are going
to be hard regulatory issues.
At the same time, we do
believe that's worth some
of the biggest
opportunities are.
We do recognize that
a lot of investors
run away from those
things because
of some of the regulatory risk.
As a result, it creates pretty
interesting opportunities.
So it sort of
depends on the space.
We invested two or three
years ago, for example,
in a company, Handy,
that in some ways
is like Uber for cleaning your
homes and apartments, things
like that.
And when we did it-- sort
of a two sided marketplace--
we knew there were going to
be some policy risks about how
do you deal with these 1099
workers, what kind of benefits
should they be provided?
But that was a risk
that we thought
was a reasonable kind of risk
to take, because we thought--
MARY GROVE: How
are they doing now?
STEVE CASE: They're
doing quite well.
They're doing quite well.
There was a competitor
out here, actually,
I think Google Ventures backed.
MARY GROVE: Homejoy.
STEVE CASE: We crushed.
We crushed.
[LAUGHTER]
MARY GROVE: He's
an active investor,
a very proud investor.
STEVE CASE: There's
still some work to do,
but Handy's got good traction.
MARY GROVE: I'm going to ask
you quickly about partnerships,
and as you can tell from our
own work and the partners
in the room today, we
believe very deeply in that.
So can you give me an
example of, in your mind,
just a super successful
example of a startup
partnering with a major
incumbent or large
organization?
What's the playbook
for entrepreneurs?
STEVE CASE: Well,
it's actually what
Google did with AOL, even though
it happened a bunch of years
ago.
When we did this
deal-- and most of you
obviously weren't
here at the time.
I don't remember how many
employees Google had.
MARY GROVE: 200.
STEVE CASE: 200 or so.
MARY GROVE: Something like that.
STEVE CASE: If you talk
to Larry or Sergey--
I think might even made
before Eric joined.
One of the most transformative
deals for Google
was a deal to essentially
have AOL, which at the time
was pretty dominant, essentially
use Google for search.
And that's why as
part of that deal
AOL essentially acquired 5% of
Google at a pretty low value.
That actually dramatically
accelerated Google's growth,
dramatically accelerated the
algorithm kind of refinement
that really helped make
Google what Google is today.
So that's an
example where it was
sort of a pragmatic
decision on both sides--
Google saying I want that
additional distribution,
and we're willing
to share revenues
and willing to give up part
of our company to do it.
On AOL's side, we did believe
that Google technology was
better technology, and so
we replaced what we had,
and it was kind of a thing that
would benefit both companies.
And that mindset of--
in the third wave
is going to be much
more important.
How do the start ups
figure out ways to partner
with some of the larger
incumbents in health care,
or education, or some
of these other sectors?
And how do the large
companies figure out
ways to understand what
the entrepreneur is doing?
One of the things I really
respect about Mary's work,
and more broadly, Google's
work, is figuring out ways
to stay close to the
entrepreneurial world
and understand what's
happening on the periphery
and try to be positioned
as a friend of disruption
not just a-- when
companies get larger,
they tend to shift from
being attackers to defenders,
and less of the art
of the possible,
and more about hedging the
downside, but the really
great companies like
Google, or Apple,
or Amazon, who, in
the last decade,
have really figured out a way
to continue to run their core
business effectively while
leaning into the future
and seizing some of
these new opportunities.
MARY GROVE: Great.
Great.
Now, so along the lines
of entrepreneurship,
you and I talked a
lot about failure
as a concept-- failing,
failing quickly,
learning from it, something that
separates great entrepreneurs.
So what is your greatest
failure do you consider,
and what did you learn from it?
STEVE CASE: Well,
I've had a lot.
Certainly, as I
talked, the failure
of the merger with Time
Warner would be one of them.
The failure early
on to get traction.
It really took us a decade
before we really got going.
I thought it was
so obvious when we
started that of course
everybody would get online.
It took us a lot of years
to finally break through.
One of the really--
what we thought
was such a devastating failure,
might kill the company,
was in the late 80s.
I think it was '89.
Our strategy in the first
few years in the late 80s
was to-- because we didn't
have a lot of capital.
We raised $1 million of venture
capital to get started-- was
we partnered with
PC manufacturers
to create essentially
white label services.
So we partnered with Commodore.
Some of you may remember
the Commodore 64--
to launch a service
called Q-Link.
We partnered with Radio
Shack at the time.
We had a big computer alliance.
Launched something
called PC Link.
We partnered with IBM to launch
something called Promenade.
We partnered with Apple
to launch something
called Apple Link
Personal Edition.
It was the first
time, I believe,
Apple ever licensed their
brand name to another company,
and we basically
created this service.
And they were going to
work with us to market it,
but not long after
we launched it
we were at
loggerheads, because we
wanted to give away the software
for free to get membership.
They wanted to sell
software because that
was their model at the time.
We wanted to
distribute it broadly.
They wanted only
to distribute it
through Apple authorized stores.
There were just a bunch
of different issues.
So one day they said, we
want out of this deal.
We don't want to
work with you guys.
We don't want to partner.
We don't want to
license our name,
and so they basically said they
wanted to tear up the contract,
and they paid us a few million
dollars to go away quietly.
And we then had
to-- we thought we
might be done because that was
a key growth strategy for us,
so it was pretty scary.
That led us to say, well,
we can't call it Apple Link
anymore.
What do we call it?
Which led to essentially
renaming it America Online,
and then that plus some
other things we did
really is what
accelerated our growth.
So that was an
example of something
that was a failed partnership
that really could have been
game over that ended up
opening some new doors that we
were able to pursue.
MARY GROVE: Turn it around.
So I'm going to ask you one
last question of my own.
Then I'd like to open it up
to the audience for questions,
so please get ready.
I want to talk
about job creation,
and throughout the book you
had some really interesting
statistics around how
entrepreneurs really are
the backbone of job creation.
I know, Steve, that you did
a lot of work leading up
to the JOBS Act.
So talk to us about
what do you think
the major sources
of job creation
will be in the third wave.
STEVE CASE: Well, I think
it's an important question.
I think the key, if
you look at the data--
and an organization called the
[? Copland ?] Foundation does
a lot of research on
this-- is the big job
creation comes from young
high growth startups.
It doesn't come from small
businesses like main street
restaurants.
In aggregate, they
account for a lot of jobs,
but they don't create
a lot of net jobs
because one restaurant might
go under, a new one might open.
In aggregate, it
doesn't create jobs.
And large companies, the Fortune
500 companies, in aggregate
don't create a lot
of jobs either.
It's these young-- what
some call gazelle companies.
So it is finding the Google's
that are a few people or maybe
a few dozen people
that might end up
being hundreds, or thousands,
or tens of thousands of people.
And so that's the key
thing to focus on.
And one of the
key focuses is one
of the things we work with
Google for Entrepreneurs on
is this concept of
the rise of the rest,
that we-- I'm sitting
in Silicon Valley.
I'm proud of Silicon Valley.
I think Silicon Valley
will continue to be great,
and lot of great companies
will start here and scale here,
but there are also now
great entrepreneurs all
over the country, indeed
all over the world.
And in this third
wave, I think you'll
see both the regionalization
and the globalization
of entrepreneurship, and that's
critically important if we're
going to create jobs
all across the country
and create opportunity
and even prosperity all
across the country.
A lot of people do feel
frustrated and left
out-- a lot of cities
that feel left behind,
and there's a way to
bring them in to being
a more significant
force in the third wave
than they were generally
in the second wave.
So that's a big
focus of our efforts
both at Revolution and
at the Case Foundation.
Obviously it's a key focus
for Google for Entrepreneurs,
as well, which is not to
say that we're predicting
the decline of Silicon Valley.
We are predicting the
rise of these other places
around the country,
indeed, around the world.
And the surprising
statistic there-- again, I
say this knowing that I'm
sitting at Google in Silicon
Valley and sort of
like, well, how can
you possibly be talking
about the rise of anything
other than Silicon Valley
because we're so awesome
and do everything so perfectly?
But last year 75% of
venture capital-- 75%--
went to three states--
California, New York,
and Massachusetts-- 75%--
but that does not reflect
the distribution of great
entrepreneurs with great ideas.
It's really more of
a historical anomaly,
probably because Silicon
Valley has done so well,
probably could most venture
capital is based here.
It's more convenient to get
in a car than get on a plane,
but that's going to start
changing in the third wave.
And rest will start
rising in this third wave.
So you want to stay
in Silicon Valley?
Great.
It will continue to be great,
but if you grew up in Detroit,
and want to be part of
the resurgence of Detroit,
or feel like there
is great opportunity
to be in Nashville or Madison
because of what they're doing,
or Baltimore because of what
they're doing with health IT,
I think there will be
more of that opportunity
in this third wave than
there was in the second wave.
Just a few examples
just to highlight this,
because people when I first
talk about this go really?
What, are there real companies
outside of California,
New York, and Massachusetts?
MARY GROVE: How
many cities have you
been to on the rise of
the rest [INAUDIBLE] now?
STEVE CASE: On these bus
tours, we've been to 19,
and we started one
with Mary in Detroit,
which is a great story, because
75 years ago Detroit kind of
was Silicon Valley.
It was actually the
hottest city in the country
when the car was the hot
technology of the day.
Kind of lost its way.
Its fighting its way back,
and so that was a great place
to start.
So we've been to a bunch
of different cities,
but here is just a few examples.
Hottest health IT company,
probably Epic systems,
which is Madison,
Wisconsin-- 10,000 employees.
Basically dominate the
electronic medical records
business for hospitals.
One of the hottest VR companies
backed by over $1 billion
of venture capital, including
from Google, Magic Leap.
Do you know where they are?
AUDIENCE: Florida.
STEVE CASE: Fort
Lauderdale, Florida.
They're not in Palo Alto.
They're not in Boston.
They're not in New York City.
They're in Fort
Lauderdale, Florida.
Hottest company focused on
initially with athletic wear,
but then also focused
on health tech,
a lot of things around
wearables and wellness.
Under Armour, worth $25
billion or something.
They're in Baltimore, Maryland.
There is now a half a dozen
multibillion dollar SaaS
companies on one
street in Provo, Utah.
Salesforce bought a
company for $3 billion
called ExactTarget that was
in Indianapolis, Indiana.
So there are plenty
of examples of what's
happening in different
parts of the country,
and again, we need to
continue to support ecosystems
in this area and
other areas, but we
need to figure out
ways to lift up
these other places so that there
can be more job creation there.
The part of the Detroit story
I didn't tell you was it
was Silicon Valley 75 years ago.
It lost 60% of its population
in the last half century
and then went
bankrupt because it
lost that job creation engine,
lost its entrepreneurial mojo.
There are lots of parts of the
country that are suffering.
That's part of the
reason why this election
season has been kind of noisy.
There are a lot of people
feeling frustrated and left
out, and we need
to understand that,
and we need to make sure
entrepreneurs anywhere have
a shot, and, oh, by the
way, entrepreneurs that
are more diverse have a shot.
It's not just a
diversity of place,
but a diversity of background.
Last year 90% of venture
capital went to men.
99%-- less than 1% went
to people of color.
Doesn't seem smart.
Doesn't seem right.
So how do you make sure that
you level the playing field
and create-- just as
the internet essentially
democratized access
to information,
in this third wave, we're
democratizing access
to opportunity and
entrepreneurship.
MARY GROVE: Well, reading
your book makes me incredibly
optimistic about the future.
I want to open it up for
questions from the audience.
AUDIENCE: How
important do you think
entrepreneurship is to education
or academia in general?
And do you think
it is an accident
that 75% of the VC capital
went to states where
we have leading
universities that
perhaps have a longer tradition
in sponsoring entrepreneurship?
And again, what
are your thoughts
about the relationship
between universities
and entrepreneurship?
STEVE CASE: I think
it's important,
and there's no question
that this region benefits
from Stanford, and Caltech,
and other things that are here.
No question Boston benefits from
MIT, and Harvard, and so forth.
No question about that,
but it's also true
that there are
great universities
in the rest of the country.
Arguably the best university
in the country-- probably
in the world-- around
robotics is Carnegie Mellon
in Pittsburgh.
There's a reason Uber put
its driverless car operation
in Pittsburgh, not here--
because of Pittsburgh's history
of making stuff.
Again, it kind of led the
whole Industrial Revolution
as the steel capital and
also their expertise,
particularly coming
out of Carnegie Mellon
around engineering, and
particularly around robotics,
and things like that.
And if you go
around the country,
there are different
universities that
actually do have excellence
in a lot of different areas,
even though what was originally
called the Mosaic browser,
for example, was-- I
think it was in Illinois.
That was not here,
not in Boston.
So I think it's a misnomer that
you cannot build a significant
ecosystem without-- anchored
by a research university,
but it does certainly help,
but there are also places all
around the country that have
pretty strong universities
doing some pretty interesting
things in some of these
sectors.
The last point I make in
this third wave sector,
if you look at
things like health
care, and transportation,
food, and so forth, 75%
of the Fortune 500 companies
that lead those sectors
are actually in the middle of
country and not on the coast.
So if partnerships
become more important,
I'll bet you there are a lot of
ag tech companies in St. Louis.
Why?
Monsanto is in St. Louis.
Tens of thousands of
engineers understand farming.
I'll bet there are a
couple hundred ag tech
startups in that St.
Louis area a decade ago.
Louisville, as well,
has expertise there.
In health IT, I
mentioned some of them.
Baltimore, because of Johns
Hopkins, really rocking.
A lot of things happening
in places like Nashville
because there are a lot
of health care companies
based there.
So there actually
are a lot of activity
in each of these
sectors, and some
of the best-- M.D. Anderson
in Texas is probably
the leader in cancer
research, for example.
There's a lot of
things happening
a lot of different places, not
just here in Boston and New
York, and that will be more
evident in this third wave--
AUDIENCE: That's kind of point.
STEVE CASE: --and more
capital to flow there.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: It was
kind of my point.
AUDIENCE: What advice would you
have for those of us working
on the rise of the rest
outside of the United States,
especially in areas that don't
have these kinds of staples
of histories, of other companies
or universities kind of holding
things together?
STEVE CASE: That's
a great question,
and obviously Google is
doing some work there.
We've done some, as well.
Our focus has mostly been
in the United States,
but we did help the Case
foundation launch a venture
capital fund in the West Bank
five or six years ago backing
Google, and Cisco, and
others with a sense
that maybe if you-- there
were startups in Ramallah,
there would be more of a sense
there's opportunity there.
And we're hoping
that might be a way
to provide a more-- create
a more peaceful region.
Done a lot of things in
Africa over this past summer.
A lot interesting things
happening in Kenya, Nigeria,
Ghana, and developing
some interesting momentum
around some of those particular
challenges in the some
of those regions.
Huge infrastructure
challenges and [INAUDIBLE],
but also really innovative
things around energy,
particularly solar in
rural villages in Africa,
understanding a problem
that we wouldn't
appreciate sitting here or
most parts of the country.
Recently spent
some time in Cuba.
I think that's going
to surprise people
as the rules get
relaxed to allow
more business to be conducted.
I think it's going to be rise
of a very start up nation,
but the playbook is not that
dissimilar to the playbook
that's being run within
the United States,
because even though it may
feel like from other parts
of the world like somehow the
United States has it right
as this innovative
entrepreneurial nation,
the reality is it's
not evenly dispersed,
and that places like Detroit,
and Nashville, and New Orleans,
and so forth are really
fighting to build more network
density within their
community, more
collaboration within
their community,
try to win this
battle for talent,
particularly boomerang talent.
How do you get people
who grew up there, went
to school there to feel like
it's time to come back there?
How do you get more attention
around the companies,
drive more capital?
Which is why the Google
demo day and things
like that are so important.
So actually it's not that
dissimilar to the challenges
in most parts of this country.
It's how do you just create
a sense of possibility
and momentum and get
that network effect
work in your favor.
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering if you had
any thoughts around the types
of leader or entrepreneur
that might come
through the third wave?
Is it going to be distinct
from the types leader
and entrepreneur that's been
successful first, second wave?
Types of skills, et cetera?
Is it going to be
marked, different?
STEVE CASE: It might be.
It might be.
There are things-- I
think time will tell.
I would not be surprised if
the founding CEOs of not all,
but many of the third wave
companies were a little older
and didn't have a little
more domain expertise,
because my guess
is, if partnerships
are more important, having
some credibility in that field,
whether it be
health or education,
is probably going
to be important.
Probably going to be hard to
get people to take you seriously
at Stanford University,
or Cleveland Clinic,
or what have you if you
don't have some-- either you
or somebody on your team
has some of that expertise.
The policy regulatory
things are sticky,
and they're
complicated and require
an understanding of that.
So having some of
that perspective
may be important, as well.
So I think there will probably
be a few less of the 20
something dorm room start
ups, and there will probably
be more diverse
teams that really
have a broader set of skills.
I'm sure there will be some
exceptions to the rule,
but I think the engineering
skills of course
will be important, because
at the core a lot of this
is about technology.
Some of the people skills will
probably become more important
because those probably
are pretty essential
in terms of forming partnerships
and engaging on policy.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Steve.
I have a question
around capital.
So in a lot of these markets,
you have great entrepreneurs,
you have great
ideas, but we often
hear that they don't have the
same access to capital, as you
mentioned around 75%,
but it doesn't mean
these towns don't have money?
STEVE CASE: Right.
AUDIENCE: Right,
and it doesn't mean
that they don't have investors
investing in other things.
What's your thought
around how do
we help direct investment
towards these entrepreneurs,
specifically in this third wave
of the type of entrepreneurs
that will created in places
like Detroit, Nashville,
and other places?
STEVE CASE: Well, I think
there's several parts to it,
and the first part is
creating a sense of momentum
within the city to get money
in the city of the sidelines.
Most of these rise
of rest cities
there's actually a lot of
money that could be invested,
but they're not really
paying attention
to what's happening
in the startup,
and they don't really
understand the importance of it,
and part of the argument I
make when I do these visits is,
if you want to have a vibrant
community 25 years from now,
invest in your startups
today, because there are going
to be-- some of
them are going to be
the job creators of tomorrow.
And if you're not
investing them today,
you're not going to look
too good 25 years now.
So it's either good
investment opportunities,
and that should
be a driver there.
Some of these
successes I mentioned
like Epic and Under Armour--
people who were early investors
made a lot of
money, but also it's
a way to strengthen
your community.
So mobilizing the local
money, I think, is important,
because obviously
national investors
are looking for that
local signal of nobody
in Des Moines investing
in the company.
Why should I in San Francisco,
or New York, or DC, or wherever
invest in it?
So that's one.
Crowdfunding is another one.
One of the reasons I was
a pretty strong advocate
for this JOBS Act that passed
a few years ago jumpstarting
our business startups,
because I think crowdfunding
can be a game changer and it
can level the playing field,
because a lot of
people don't have money
and don't know people
who have money.
And the project sites
like Kickstarter and Ugogo
have demonstrated that
it's more about the idea
and less about what you look
like and who do you know.
And so as that shifts-- and it's
going to take a number of years
to also allow equity
and debt crowd funding--
I think that's going to open
up a lot of opportunities
for a lot of people
in a lot of places
that otherwise wouldn't have it.
And the third is to, like we're
doing today with the Google
demo day, educate investors
in places like California,
and New York, and Massachusetts,
where most of the money
is, that there actually are
great opportunities there,
and, oh by the way, because
there's less investors paying
attention, the valuation of that
company in Des Moines or New
Orleans is less than if that
same company was in Palo Alto
or Manhattan, yet if
it's successful and goes
public or gets acquired,
it gets acquired at retail,
but you can invest in rise
the rest cities at wholesale.
So essentially there's
an arbitrage opportunity,
so it gets more investors
to pay attention
and kind of get on planes.
So it's some mix of
mobilizing local support,
using crowdfunding as a
platform to-- use the internet
to raise capital for more
people with more ideas and more
places, and then take some
time, but try to create
more momentum around
what's happening
in the rest of the country.
My guess is 10 years from now
all the leading venture firms
will have regional strategies.
They'll call it
different things.
They'll organize it
differently, but the days
of their basically
saying-- and some
still do-- that I'm only
going to invest in companies
I can drive to will be
viewed as a relic of history
and I even result in a lot
of missed opportunities.
Even though I love Silicon
Valley and still think
Silicon Valley will be great.
I want to make that clear.
MARY GROVE: And I
would like to close
with just a quick,
rapid fire fill
in the blank for you, Steve.
So I'm going to say a
phrase or statement.
I'm going to ask you
to fill in the blank.
STEVE CASE: This is
like a Rorschach test.
I hate that.
MARY GROVE: My first AOL Instant
Messenger screen name was?
STEVE CASE: Steve.
[LAUGHTER]
MARY GROVE: Steve.
STEVE CASE: Hey, it
pays to be early.
[LAUGHTER]
MARY GROVE: One startup
you should all go check out
right now is?
STEVE CASE: That's
a good question.
AUDIENCE: Mati.
STEVE CASE: What's that?
MARY GROVE: Mati.
STEVE CASE: Mati.
Oh, Mati was a company
that won last year
Google for Entrepreneurs
in North Carolina.
And if you want to drink
it, it's right back there.
[LAUGHTER]
No, I-- that had to
be hard, because we're
championing dozens of
cities and really thousands
of entrepreneurs.
It would be like picking
your favorite child,
so I would say my favorite is
actually just understanding
what's happening in this third
wave and wildly different
understanding why it will
likely happen in places,
and pay attention
to what's happening,
and try to be supportive of
these rise of the rest cities.
MARY GROVE: The best pizza
I developed as director
of new pizza development was?
STEVE CASE: I was only there
about a year, but the key--
MARY GROVE: You had to have
had some pizza in that year.
STEVE CASE: We didn't really--
we tried a bunch of things.
I'm not sure any of them
actually got much traction,
but as you mentioned
earlier, delivery
was one of the things that was--
at that time, very few places
delivered, and that was a big
focus that then obviously did
get traction.
Now everybody delivers.
MARY GROVE: Final question.
My advice for all
of you as Googlers?
STEVE CASE: I think you're
doing remarkably well.
So let's start with that point.
I think trying to figure
out how to maintain
this culture of being an
attacker, as I said before,
is critically important.
I think actually the
structure and alphabet
seems logical to me to kind of
create that kind of dynamic.
The challenge
there-- a little bit
like I was saying with the
Time Warner situation--
is make sure as things become
more separate that you don't
have the ability still to drive
some synergy and collaboration
where it makes sense.
In some of these things, it's
not going to be as necessary,
but where it makes sense, how
do you continue to drive that.
And how do you
recognize that things
are going to continue
to change and not
have this mentality,
particularly in your group,
or you'll get
cocky or complacent
and continue to
kind of push ahead.
And pay it forward a little bit.
This is a company that
has benefited greatly
from the support
of a lot of people.
In whatever sector
you care about,
whatever place you care about,
how do you be helpful, as well?
And maybe that's
even-- if you're still
going to say Google
and still going
to be living in this
area, maybe there's
a way through crowdfunding
or visiting once
a year to the place you grew up
or the place you went to school
and be part of helping other
entrepreneurs in other places
and part of this kind of
rise of the rest movement.
It's not just about what
you're doing directly.
It's about the impact
you can have broadly,
and because of the
success of Google
and the respect of Google,
you, as an ambassador,
I think could really
be transformative.
So I just encourage you to
think about that as a way
to have impact in the world
beyond what you're doing day
to day, because that
ultimately will lift up
more entrepreneurs
in more places,
and that ultimately will result
in a fairer and more prosperous
world.
MARY GROVE: Steve Case, thank
you so much for your time.
STEVE CASE: Thank
you all for coming.
MARY GROVE: And
I'll see you later.
[APPLAUSE]